hey guys my name is Jess McDonald and
welcome back to day 2 of 8 3 2015 the
press conferences may be over but we've
still got plenty of cool gaming bits and
pieces to tell you about so let's get
into that mobile games do tend to be a
pretty unpopular topic among hardcore
gamers but right now there's one mobile
game that has everybody's attention and
that's all out shelter the vault
management app has been out all of three
days and it's already the top free app
on iTunes and fourth overall in the
revenue chart despite the pile of money
Bethesda must be rolling in they said
they didn't create the game to make
money but rather just to get fallout out
there although the game is free to play
you can buy lunch boxes for 99 cents a
pop or get 14 for twenty bucks if you're
really keen for the extra content inside
for those of you who are much like me
are feeling a little left out with your
Android Bethesda has said they're
working on an android version which will
hopefully launch in a few months you
know when everybody else is stopped
playing it the Final Fantasy 7 remake
announced at sony's press conference
we've met with a pretty positive
reception but it might not be the game
you're expecting gamespot asks to
director Tetsuya Nomura if the remake
would be following at their 7th
narrative exactly or if it would feature
new elements and the answer may make
purist fans a little nervous Nomura
explained quote you'll have this
extremely very very pretty final fantasy
7 existing on the same plane we feel
that if that happens it's like why have
the same exact game we think that if a
game is on a certain platform and that
platform becomes obsolete then we'd
recommend playing the new port version
finally Mirror's Edge wants you to lay
out the guns when catalyst comes out in
fact the new game won't even let you
pick one up although you did have the
option to pop caps in your foes in the
first game that feature won't make an
appearance
catalyst senior producer Sarah Jensen
told polygon quote we'd completely
removed that aspect of the game you
can't even pick them up not such a big
deal for gamers who preferred stylish
parkour escapes anyway but leave me your
thoughts on the decision on top of that
let me know down in the comments if you
think a remix would be true to the
original game or not and fly be sure to
head to gain spot for all the latest
news trailers and demos coming out of e3
and join me against Mora for the top
five news stories from the whole of e3 a
case event